ابقار الخارقه حيث نجح علماء صينيون في
استنساخ ثلاث بقرات من فصيله هوشتاين
هولنديه المنشاه والتي يمكنها انتاج
طنا من الحليب سنويا العلماء الصينيون
ينتجوا 120
جينا مستنسخا ووضعوا في امهات بديلات فيما
وصفوه بالانجاز الاقتصادي هو انجاز بالفعل
حيث يتم استيراد ما يصل الى 70% من البان
الابقار التي تحتاجها الصين من الخارج حيث
كانت الصين اعلنت في يناير عن ولاده اول
جواد مستنسخ من حصان ينتمي لسلاله عاليه
وهو مستورد من المانيا توسعت الصين خلال
السنوات الاخيره بشكل كبير في عمليات
الاستنساخ لتصبح اقل اعتمادا على
الحيوانات المستورده باهظه الثمن
تتنافس الدول لانتاج كميات كبيره من
الحليب لتلبيه احتياجات السوق كونه يدخل
في العديد من المنتجات الغذائيه تعتبر
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر دوله منتجه في
العالم لحليب البقر بنحو 103 ملايين طن
سنويا وهي الاولى ايضا في حجم استهلاك
الحليب وفي تصنيع منتجاته الثانويه الهند
هي ثاني اكثر البلدان انتاجا للحليب بسبعه
وتسعين مليون طن سنويا اذ تنتج اكثر من 9%
من حجم الانتاج العالمي للحليب الصين تاتي
ثالثه بتسعه وثلاثين طنا سنويا وتصدر
الصين حليبها فقط الى عدد قليل جدا من
البلدان الاسيويه يوجد في الصين ما يقرب
من سته ملايين الف بقره من سلاله ابقاره
هولشتاين التي يتم استيرادها على مر
السنين يخططون الان لانشاء قطيع الابقار
في غضون سنتين الى ثلاث سنوات وتستثمر
بكثافه هذه الاقار لبناء مزرعه البان من
مئه الف بقره
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا من برلين دكتور ناصر
غانم استاذ مساعد في الانتاج الحيواني
بكليه الزراعه في جامعه القاهره دكتور
ناصر يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معانا في الصباح
العربيه نجاح اول عمليه استنساخ ناجحه
لبقره من سلاله القدرات الانتاجيه الفائقه
اهميه هذا الاستنساخ
اولا صباح الخير حضرتك صباح الخير على
جميع المشاهدين طبعا هذا الانجاز مهم جدا
لانه بيعضت فكره استخدام الحيوانات
المستنسخه في التحسين الوراثي وزياده
الانتاج عن الطرق التقليديه في التحسين
الوراثي اللي هي عن طريق الانتخاب فمعنى
ان السين تقدر
تستنسخ بقر ويعطي معدل عالم للانتاج
معناها ان هذه الابطال بعد كده ممكن
نشرها ونشر التراكيب الوراثيه ليس فقط في
الصين بل في الدول الاخرى
طيب يا دكتور ناصر
دكتور ناصر بالعاده الابقار بيدللوها بين
جبال سويسرا حتى تكون عايشه بحاله نفسيه
كتير منيحه وتدور حليب اكثر اليوم لما
بنحكي عن بقره صينيه
ومستنسخه ستدر حليب اكثر كيف
وهل بنفس الجوده
نصائح البقره الطبيعيه من مصدرها الام
الرئيسيه ولا يختلف تركيبها الكيماوي ولا
مذاقها ولا اي حاجه خالص
وسليمه من الناحيه الغذائيه سليمه على
الانسان
دكتور ناصر
طنا من الالبان سنويا هل هذا سيحل مشكله
ازمه الالبان حول العالم وقلتم انه
الموضوع لن يقتصر على الصين هل مصر يعني
نعرف انه استنساخ الابقار يحتاج الى
امكانات يحتاج الى تكلفه ماليه باهظه والى
بيئه معمليه هل مصر مستعده لعمليه
الاستنساخ
والله احنا في مصر بنعتمد على استيراد
الابقار المحسنه وراثيا اللي هي عاليه
الانتاج لكن في مصر ليست المشكله بس ان
احنا نحسن عن طريق الاستنساخ او نجيب عدد
كبير من البقر على الانتاج ولكن في مشكله
كبيره جدا وظهرت حتى في الاونه الاخيره
وهي مشكله الموارد العلفيه لان حتى الفقره
العاليه الانتاج معناها احتياجاتها من
الغذاء عالي جدا يبقى كل مزاد انتاج
الحيوان من اللبن معناه احتياجات غذائيه
من المواد العنفيه هتزيد فمعناها ان ده من
زياده الموارد العلفيه فنقدر عمليه
استنساخ لحاولات محسنه وراثيا عاليه
الادراك يعني محتاج
بنيه تحتيه مهمه بالذات في توفير المحاصيل
والموارد العرفيه دكتور ناصر
يعني مثلا روسيا قبل كم سنه كانت تستنسخت
بقره هي مضاده للحساسيه يعني مثلا حليب
لاكتوز فري فبالتالي خصوصا 70% من البشر
بعانوا من هذه الازمه كيف ستخدمنا هذه
الابقار المستنسخه على المدى القريب
والمدى البعيد بعد ذلك
طبعا على المدى القريب هي الاستنساخ ده
تقنيه اساسيه لكن في بعض اعيان بندمج معها
تقنيات اخرى زي تقنيه التعديل الجيني
بمعنى ان انا بستنسخ بقره متميز فرنسيا
ولكن ممكن اعدل بعض الجينات مثلا عاوز
ازود نسبه الدهن في البقره
يبقى عندها انتاج لبن عالي ونسبه فيها
كمان عالي فممكن اعدل ما عمليه الاستعمال
عمليه حقن لمواد كيماويه معينه بتعمل
تعديل للجينات المسؤوله او لجين المسؤول
عن نسبه الدسم او حتى على المدى البعيد مع
وجود مشكله تغير المناخ والبلو بالورمنج
وهنحتباس الحراري معناه ان احنا لا مش مش
هنبص ان البقره تكون عاليه الادرار بس لا
لازم البقره يكون متكيفه مع ارتفاع درجه
الحراره ونسبه الاوبئه والامراض
التي يعقد عمليه زياده الحراره نبدا مما
يستلزم ان احنا الفقره دي هنعدلها جينيا
ونعمل لها استنساخ لصفات الانتاج مع صفات
الاقلمه
وبالاضافه طبعا اخرى مرغوبه زي مثلا
بعض الناس اللي هم عندهم حساسيه اللاكتوز
بيتم تعديل الجيني بحيث ان هي تبقى لابتوس
فري او
مرغوبه او اي حته صفات طعم ممكن تعديلها
جينيا طب على امل انت حول عمليات
الاستنساخ ازمه الالبان حول العالم شكرا
جزيلا من برلين الدكتور ناصر غانم استاذ
مساعد في انتاج وحيواني بكليه الزراعه
جامعه القاهره شكرا جزيلا